- Good morning believe nation!
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs will
solve all of the world's major problems.
So, to help you on your
journey today's message is
ask great questions.
Over to you, Timothy Ferris.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- I find that levels of
success in almost any industry
or area correlate to a person
asking great questions.
In some cases they seem absurd.
In fact, the hallmark in a
way of great questions is they
sound completely ridiculous.
So, someone might ask like
Peter Teal why can't you achieve
your ten year goals in
the next six months?
As a thought exercise
that's a good question to
answer for yourself.
And, these types of questions
come up surprisingly often
with very, very impressive folks.
Whether it's in business, military,
entertainment or otherwise.
And the way you can get
better at questions is by
studying interviews in part.
So, I studied Larry King.
I studied Charlie Rose.
I studied Terry Gross.
I studied dot, dot, dot,
dot go down the list.
I studied Tony Robbins who
does in person one on one
interventions, at his events, in front of
10,000, 5,000 people
and he's just genius with
how he uses his questions
to pattern interrupt and
grab someone's attention.
And divert them in a more
productive direction.
Now, why is that relevant?
It's relevant because
thinking is the process of
asking questions.
You're asking yourself questions and then
you're answering them in your own head.
So, if you get better at
asking other people questions
you get better at asking
yourself questions.
Which means you are a,
you're improving your thought
performance and level of thinking.
- One of my favorite exercises
to do both for myself and for
entrepreneurs I'm working
with is try to turn limiting
statements into how questions.
Turn limiting statements
into how questions.
So, as an example turn a
statement like "I can't do this
"because I have a full time job."
into a, "How do I do this
while I have a full time job?"
"I can't start this company
because I don't have any money."
into, "How do I start this business
"without having any money?"
As soon as you can move
from a limiting statement
that you absorbed and feel like,
"Well this is just true.
"I have a limited life,
I have limited resources,
"I have limited access, I'm limited,
"everything's limited, I'm never
going to achieve anything."
As soon as you can move
to that state to a how.
How do I accomplish it with
these restrictions limitations?
Then, you start to break out of your box.
Then, you start to have the ability to do
more amazing things.
And so it's catching yourself
to know when you're saying
really limiting statements
and then asking that question
of how can I accomplish it
except these limitations
that I have right now?
Part of the challenge though,
is catching yourself and
knowing when you're actually
saying a limiting statement.
Because again, so much
of it is subconscious.
So much of the time we're
just automatically living on
small mode.
Automatically living on auto-pilot.
You know, living by other
peoples' expectations
and limitations, constantly.
We're not constantly going off
living big, doing huge things
We're living in survival mode, so often.
So, being able to catch
those limiting statements
can be difficult.
Here's one of my favorite
exercises on how to fix it.
Look at yourself in the mirror.
Go do it.
Look yourself in the mirror.
Pull out your phone and look
at yourself in the phone.
And ask yourself, "Why
am I not more successful?
"Why have I not hit my goals?
"Why have I had this goal
for the past three years,
"and I haven't made progress on it?
"Why is still a someday going?
"Why have I not done a thing
that I said I want to do?
"That seems important to
me, why have I not done it?"
And somewhere in there is
going to be an answer, right?
Like don't look away
until you get an answer.
And then from there that's one
of your limiting statements.
That's probably the most
powerful limiting statements
that you have.
Well, I'm not able to be a success.
I haven't hit my goals because
I didn't go to University,
and everybody who has
success went to University.
That's the story you're having
to play over and over and
over and over again, in your mind.
Great, that's your limiting statement.
Let's turn that into a how.
How do I accomplish my
goal and start my business
without having a University education?
How do I surround myself
with resources and people
who prove to me that it's
possible to go off and do this?
Because lots of entrepreneurs
have done it, right?
So, I find that exercise so helpful.
Look at yourself in the mirror,
or write down on a piece of paper.
"I have not accomplished
my big goals yet because."
Write it down, maybe
there's multiple reasons.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
Maybe fill up the whole
page of reasons why
you're not more successful.
Why you haven't hit your goals.
Each one of those are limiting
statements and as long as you
continue to believe them.
As long as you continue to act by them,
most of the time subconsciously.
You sound just like you
everyday wake up and just remind
yourself, I don't have
a university education
so I'm not going to be successful.
It's not like you have
these negative mantras,
you just do it automatically.
It's how you're living
your life by default.
The limitations are hard to
catch because it's just default.
So, if you build your list
of the reasons, and then
start attacking them.
Ask yourself how questions.
As soon as you ask yourself how.
How can I?
Instead of just accepting
this negative situation,
the box starts to open.
The possibilities start to open.
You move from a negative
place to a positive one.
You move from a resourceless
state to a resourceful one.
Because you're forcing your
brain to answer the question.
How can I do this despite not
having this, or despite being
this or despite growing up like this?
How can I still go off and do it?
And if you get used to
asking those potential filled
questions then your brain
will find the answer.
You're asking better
questions as opposed to living
a really limited life.
That for the most part is self-imposed.
So the question of the day
today is, I'd like to quickly go
through this exercise with you.
Ask yourself what is the one
reason, just pick one to start,
you may have a huge list,
but what is one reason
why you're not more successful?
Why you haven't accomplished
your main goals?
Write it down on the comments
below and the next to it
write down the how-to version of it.
How can I, version of it.
And if you really want to
take it to the next step,
answer that question.
Answer the how to.
I think if you do that
consistently, it'll open up a world
of difference for you
and I'd love it to spark,
right here on this episode.
So, leave it down on the comments below.
I'm really curios to see
what you have to say.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Mike Philips.
Mike thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
I really appreciate the support Mike
and I hope you enjoyed the book.
So, thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and what ever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- How would you tell us to
develop a habit of curiosity?
- Well you know what, people do look at me
and see me as creative because
I've written so many books.
And I am curious but when
I started off in college,
in my freshman psych
class they gave us a test
for each student to take on creativity.
And there were 17 in that class,
I can remember it well, and
I was at the bottom of
the class on creativity.
I mean, I was like, number
17 out of 17 and the teacher
posted the scores and
so I saw how bad I was.
And, then I really felt
bad not only because
I wasn't creative but I
was going to go pastor,
I was going to go into ministry,
I was going to go teach,
I was going to do sermons.
And then I got to thinking to myself,
"I'm going to be another boring preacher."
And then that just gripped me I thought,
"Oh, this is going to be awful.
"I'm going to bore people all my life."
You know what I mean?
And then I'm going to ask them
to pay while they hear me.
I mean, this is an awful deal.
And so, two things I did, and
I talk about it in the book.
One of them is I started filing.
I started taking thoughts
and quotes, and the reason I
started doing that is I
thought, "If I'm not going to be
good at what I say, I need to
quote somebody that is good."
And so I started filing things
that other people would say
so I'd go around well Kim
said, you know what I mean and
Joe said and Suzy said
and so that at least
I would be a little more interesting
and that's how it started.
But the big breakthrough, the
big breakthrough I had was,
and this will help everyone if ...
How many of you would
like to be more creative?
Let me see your hands, okay.
How many of you'd like to
just absolutely have an
imagination that just
took you to a new level?
You know what I'm saying?
How many already have that
because you're on drugs?
Okay, okay.
Here's the key, this'll work for ya.
I promise it'll work for you
because it worked for me.
I made a major change in my
early 30s from just having
answers and being a leader
that just had to cast visions,
show everybody what I was
doing and where we were going.
And I started asking
intentional questions.
And I became a person, I
ask questions all the time.
Everyday I ask questions.
And I have found just asking
questions will take you
on exciting journeys
more than anything else.
You're great, you excel in that Ken.
I've watched you over the years.
You'd excel really in that.
But for my early years I didn't
ask enough questions and so
therefore I didn't get enough
ideas and thoughts from others.
So, when people say, "I
want to be more creative
"What's step one?"
Step number one is ask more questions.
Just go to people and
start asking questions.
It's amazing what you'll learn.
- But I'm obsessed with the
idea of no standard terms.
So, when we were first getting started
and took financing, our
lawyers would take us
through the documents and they'd say,
"Oh, don't worry about
it, it's all standard."
And at the time I'm
like, "Oh, sure standard.
"That's great, no issues, that's standard.
"No problem."
And I've since learned that
standard means either the person
who's walking through the
documents doesn't understand them.
Or, you could be getting
taken advantage of.
So, when someone say something
is standard just ask why.
And why and why and why
until you really understand
intricately, I think, how
the deal is structured.
I think, the big thing that
we took away from that is,
you know, standard terms
is a huge red flag.
And beyond that, when you're afraid,
just to continue asking why.